Mexico has gotta help us at the border
they're not gonna help us at the border
it's a very sad thing we do Mexico has
got to help us
a lot of people are coming in because
they want to take advantage of daca we
certainly understand the concern not
only that prescient drum cast but people
in the United States here have about
immigration what we're trying to do
precisely is to work with the United
States and Central Americans Mexican
ambassador on the show earlier the
president the administration talking
about concerns along the border this as
the Washington Post is just moving a
story citing multiple sources saying the
Trump administration is working to speed
up deportations and impose quotas on
immigration judges in other words to get
the guidelines where a new quota system
to ensure that the cases are completed
in a timely efficient and effective
manner the concern being about this
caravan of immigrants coming across or
to the border in coming days we believe
let's bring in our panel match lap
contributor with the hill EB Stoddard
associate editor at RealClearPolitics
and host of No Labels radio on Sirius XM
and guy Benson political editor at
townhall.com alright Matt we should
clarify that the president said they
were going to come across to take
advantage of daca you can't can't do
that well you can in the sense that
people confuse all these terms you have
daca which is for a certain period of
time
but then you have this group of people
that folks call dreamers and this is
what a lot of people don't realize every
day every week on that border there are
unaccompanied minors and minors who
actually are accompanied who by our own
law we have to accept into the country
so the idea that there are illegal
people coming to this country very
regularly under our laws is one of these
loopholes that President Trump wants to
stop he wants to stop this catch and
release this insane problem that leads
us to this whole question of amnesty
1020 years later you know I've asked the
Mexican ambassador about the Mexico laws
which are very strict on immigration
they deport tens of thousands repatriate
he said in numerous different ways today
but you know it's the same issue
different country right I think that in
your interview you know what was clear
and what is more important than
President Trump you know getting a lot
of backlash from conservatives after
signing a spending bill that everyone's
upset about you know just trying to
really galvanize people about a caravan
and what he calls Democratic laws that
are weakened on immigration and and
Democrats not wanting borders and
everything the most important thing here
is that it is him using Mexico as a
cudgel and NAFTA and the negotiations
that are very sense that have been
ongoing for a year Republicans are very
concerned about what's what what the
state of these negotiations are and when
he uses his sort of political bullying
on Twitter over immigration and this
Caravan arriving and the Mexicans having
a cash cow which is NAFTA and will I'll
punish them this way to get what I want
out of them on immigration at the border
using NAFTA that is the place where this
has becomes incredibly serious he can he
indeed a DHS and and if there's a
legislative fix it can do it they can go
ahead and try to mitigate this problem
with the border that's separate from the
very sensitive negotiations with Mexico
over and after right now if you look at
his negotiating style some would say
that Kim Jong un is at the table because
he was aggressive like this a B's right
it's very sensitive they're very the
negotiations are pretty detailed and
complex on NAFTA but supporters would
say why not I think the argument from
Trump supporters would be visa vie kim
jong hoon being at the negotiating table
at all and being willing to meet with
the president is the unpredictability of
the president and his administration
where i think for the first time in a
long time in pyongyang there are people
wondering are the americans going to
stick to the international script that
we've become very accustomed to or is he
gonna go rogue and do whatever he wants
but he does that work with mexico
against bush and and i think that is a
legitimate question to ask because I
think the Mexican government you were
sitting
next to their ambassador moments ago
they're probably sitting in Mexico City
wondering okay if the president is
willing to blow up these negotiations
over NAFTA because of border security
issues in this Caravan maybe we can
throw some bones to the Americans on
internal enforcement to show that we're
doing our part on our northern border
and then maybe get them off our back
because that should be a separate issue
making it convoluted in all this cross
pollination is very difficult frankly
for some of us to keep track of
sometimes I don't even know if it's
strategic specifically but the general
unpredictability may sometimes lead to
positive outcomes you know what the
president says and tweets a lot of
things but behind the scenes you had the
Secretary of Homeland Security traveling
to Mexico a couple of weeks ago meeting
with officials dealing with security on
their southern border so things are
happening outside the sound and fury
perhaps yeah that's right actually this
is working the idea that the president
goes out mostly on Twitter but in other
venues as well makes it very clear over
and over again what he expects from the
American government's point of view and
there's no question that it brings
people to the table there's no question
that DHS is working with their
counterparts in the in the Mexican
government I think it's really important
what everyone has said on this panel
they repatriated over 250,000 people in
Mexico Mexico would not accept a child
at the border their laws don't say they
have to accept them like we have to
accept them we should have laws that are
sane and that bring us security at the
border just like all these other
countries we're dealing with it actually
makes a lot of sense Senator Dianne
Feinstein may be tweeting president
Trump is absolutely wrong on daca he
unilaterally rescinded daca for no
reason that has rejected every single
bipartisan proposal that would protect
dreamers from deportation simply false
to say that Democrats walked away from
the table
what were is the ground truth on this
well the truth is that the president's
there have been bipartisan proposals on
daca and and that obviously is something
that really should be solved in a
bipartisan way but the truth is that
when the president offered his own plan
which it was a four pronged
approach generation and other elements
many in this party thought 1.8 they
called it amnesty legalization for 1.8
million beyond the pool of the of what
Matt was referred to as that precise
dock population was was a non-starter
with conservative Republicans so it's
really unfair for him to say that the
Democrats killed it and the Democrats
don't want borders and everything yeah
the Democrats want a sweeter daca deal
that doesn't involve a lot of border
wall money they would like to you know
give some stuff for existing fixes to
existing fences they you know they have
not come far onyx onyx changing a border
wall for a daca fix so you don't think a
25 billion dollar you know allotment or
down the road vers tied to daca would
would pass I actually think that it
would it just it might it would be it
would be a bipartisan bill it would have
to be a majority it you get around these
rules of whether or not I think I think
it would it would depend it would depend
you know exactly what what the what
you're called were yeah you they don't
want the chain migration and the
diversity lottery package didn't with
that but it is a problem on the
Republican side as well as on the
Democratic side and he he said many
times to Democrats including Dianne
Feinstein that he wanted to fix this
problem and now he's walking away there
for her tweet so you know this is one
day we also have we didn't talk about it
the China push back on tariffs these are
big big things that would be page one
lead of shows but there's so much drinks
is a firehouse is another day all day
every day and yes we are seeing and this
is relatively modest at the moment but a
retaliation from the Chinese another
escalation on the path to what some of
us worry would be a trade war and the
u.s. taking shots in that trade war it
invites retaliation that's something
that does not benefit anyone and people
who believe in free trade think that
when you escalate the other side
responds and consumers in both countries
and if the economy's in both countries
lose
and these are the simple rules of
economics and we're seeing them coming
to roost in a small way and the concern
is will it develop will it get worse we
will see how it plays panel thank you